poursuivons aujourd'hui la présentation
d'un certain nombre de personnalités
politiques représentant les différentes
tendances
engagé dans la campagne électorale
aujourd'hui monsieur georges marchais
secrétaire général du parti communiste
du printemps démocratique marchand
hardiment vers le socialisme que notre
part le bâtiment saint point d'un tel
congrès du parti communiste georges
marchais vient de terminer le rapport
politique
un rapport de 4h30 axée sur la bataille
électorale et les perspectives s'ouvrent
pour la gauche
le programme comme quatre jours plus
tard il est élu secrétaire général du
parti communiste france on a beaucoup
écrit sur le leader politique
on connaît peu l'homme qui se cache
derrière le militant communiste qui êtes
vous monsieur marché un homme comme les
autres qui a une famille une vie de
famille des obligations familiales des
joies femmes et hommes dans mon quartier
les gens qui ne me connaissent bien
en dehors de ma fonction de mes
responsabilités me voir régulièrement à
les concevoir fois avec ma femme
discuter avec mes oiseaux
par exemple si vous veniez au printemps
même en été nous trouverions short dans
le jardin tranquille et les roses tous
les voisins ce maître des lieux aux
fenêtres quand il est le métallo georges
marchais adhère au parti communiste en
1947 il a 27 ans il fait ses premières
armes dans les syndicats secrétaire de
la fédération scène sud celle de maurice
thorez qu'il apprécie georges marchais
entre en 1956 comme suppléant au comité
central
trois ans plus tard il est titulaire et
accède au bureau politique
1961 il devient secrétaire du comité
central chargé de l'organisation et des
postes clés du parti février 70 son
congrès de nanterre il est secrétaire
général adjoint mais aussi porte
du parti en l'absence de waldeck rochet
écartée par la maladie enfin secrétaire
général en décembre dernier une des
fiertés de georges marchais la signature
du programme comme c'est un moment que
je n'oublierai jamais douté est ce que
vous pensiez au début devenir un jour
secrétaire général du parti communiste
évidemment non évidemment non on adhère
au parti communiste pour faire carrière
j'ai travaillé avec georges marchais non
cette entreprise qui s'appelait voisins
à l'époque il était connu par les
travailleurs comme un défenseur des
heures particulièrement à cette époque
parce qu'il y avait des luttes assez
importante pour la défense de
l'aéronautique
jn ouvriers gémeaux des bras mon
certificat d'études et c'est tout par
conséquent il m'a fallu avec l'aide du
parti sort d'où m'est personnellement un
travail considérable d'études qui ne
s'arrête jamais d'ailleurs du travail
actuel non georges marchais l'emmènera
réunion à la maison du parti avec ses
proches collaborateurs préparation de la
campagne électorale sont comptés meeting
in tehran la solution des problèmes de
salaires par exemple est étroitement
liée à une série de questions elle le
logement de logements vraiment prenant
d'autres d'autres questions
parlons de la campagne des communistes
et de la campagne de la gauche pour ces
élections et nous parlerons aussi de la
préparation du 20ème congrès du parti
communiste français
chacun s'en rend compte l'ampleur de cet
enjeu fait que cette campagne électorale
ne sera pas une campagne comme les
batailles électorales au niveau des
idées mais aussi attaques personnelles
alain peyrefitte n'at-il pas déclaré
monsieur marche est un homme qu on
hésiterait à prendre l'auto stop bref à
tort ou à raison on veut donner de
georges marchais l'image d'un dur le dur
du parti mais il est victime d'une
fausse réputation
il ya des gens qui sont très efficaces
sur la réputation des tutos l'édition et
nadau petit comme l'impression d'être de
trappes personnes qui au fond sont des
renvois d'ordre et les flux préférable
de ne pas fréquenter bien hors jeu
rappelle est présenté comme un dire
lorsqu'il n'est pas dite et c'est un
homme qui est très compréhensible traits
résume un jeu n'est pas mon sentiment
est celui ment pas c'est pas mal marché
du viol compères mieux non je pense que
une part les hommes politiques on s'est
toujours de les démarquer à partir du
moment où d'un physique quand même assez
impressionnant bond wasa aider certaines
en a fait recette
cette image de marque mais c'est vrai
que aussi bien dans la vie personnelle
privée dans la vie militante
il est tout à fait le contraire d'azur
d'abord la sensibilité gelé prouve aux
choses de la vie courante
devant un bon film lorsqu'avec l'enfant
nous écoutons beethoven nous sommes
sensibles à la musique de beethoven je
me suis lavé observés mais il est
évident par exemple dernier congrès du
parti lorsque j'étais du
secrétaire-général lorsque les camarades
m'ont témoignée par leurs
applaudissements leur confiance
j'ai eu beaucoup de balles
ok les larmes c'est évident une preuve
de sensibilité au cours de ces 25 années
de militantisme est ce qu'il n'ya pas eu
des moments difficiles des moments où
vous avez douté du parti ou du
communisme en général je pense
particulièrement aux événements aux
vagues les moments difficiles bien sûr
qu'il y a des moments difficiles quant à
douter de mon parti ou douter de la
politique de mon parti non je n'en ai
jamais douté
y compris au moment de 1968 des
événements de prime parce que j'ai
toujours considéré avec mon parti qu'il
s'agissait là d'une erreur a fait une
erreur et qu'il n'était nullement en
cause les finalités pour laquelle doute
des communistes en 1968 vous avez une
position très catégorique vous avez
traité comme betty de gauchistes
d'anarchistes allemand des propos
violents dit certains pourquoi cette
attitude tout simplement il faut
rappeler d'ailleurs le contexte époque
les gauchistes
à ce moment-là prétendait par la
propagande par leur attitude donner des
leçons à tout le monde y compris aux
partis à tous les partis à la classe
ouvrière et les gauchistes présenter un
peu comme de celle de la terre
il avait une activité des objectifs des
méthodes de lutte qui était selon nous
contraire aux intérêts des travailleurs
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons dit clairement et fermement quelle
était la position notre parti à leur
égard et je pense que ce faisant nous
avons rendu un grand service à la classe
ouvrière
certains s'interrogent sur ce que vous
avez fait pendant l'occupation
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de dire je leur
dis très simplement
c'est une calomnie que de dire j'ai été
volontairement
j'ai été comme près d'un million de
travailleurs je crois victime du service
du travail obligatoire instauré à
l'époque par le régime de vichy avec les
nazis
je n'ai donc jamais été volontaire mais
victime de st lô est d'ailleurs le
ministère des anciens combattants le
ministre des anciens combattants
sans aucun doute aussi le mail
l'intérieur le savent parfaitement bien
autre attaque plus politique celle pour
la majorité
le programme commun n'est qu'un moyen
pour le parti communiste de s'emparer du
pouvoir
d'autres aussi se pose des questions
georges marchais il ya une partie de
l'opinion qui s'interroge si elle
souhaite la prise du pouvoir de la
gauche unie et pourtant elle est un
petit peu inquiètes et c'est particulier
ne respectait pas ses engagements ne me
répondez pas que le parti gaulliste
respectera ses engagements vous le dit à
chaque fois que vous intervenez mais
comment se fait-il qu'il ya une partie
de l'opinion gauche qui est un peu
inquiète
sans doute il y a chez les gens qui
souhaitent un changement de régime est
politique des interrogations ce que vous
appelez vous des inquiétudes
c'est vrai provoquer pour une large part
pas à la campagne que mène la majorité
actuelle possible
côté fringues tout ça est évident mais
construire ne concerne je ne suis pas
inquiet de cette inquiétude dont vous
parlez peut-être aussi si vous permettez
de dire qu'il n'ya pas de modèle de
socialisme tellement malin mais il ne
s'agit pas d'instaurer la société
socialiste et nous ne disons pas ça pour
faire plaisir à qui que ce soit il
s'agit de promouvoir une politique
économique sociale démocratique
nouvelles qui permettent aux français et
aux français de bénéficier des richesses
produites par hull voilà ce dont il
s'agit est ce que vous êtes un homme
heureux
oui je suis un homme heureux parce que
le parti mais responsabilité me procure
beaucoup de satisfaction dans le sens
qu'il s'agit de penser d'agir de
travailler pour la meilleure de toutes
les causes le bonheur notre et bien
georges marchais comme nous avons pris
l'habitude de le faire depuis que nous
diffusons ses portraits je vous posais
la question traditionnelle
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose à
ajouter si j'avais eu à faire le film
je ne sais s'il aura de toute façon je
n'ai pas passé mais je trouve tout à
fait correct et je remercie et bien
sincèrement dominique laurie et ses
camarades souvenirs les réalisateurs
sans aucun doute un tel portrait aura
davantage de données de moi à l'opinion
publique une image inconnu on ne voit
plus souvent sur les tribunes que dans
notre vie privée
c'est tout à fait ceci étant dit elle
simplement ajouté que pour ce qui nous
concerne nous les communistes nous
sommes étrangers à la personnalisation
outrancière auquel nous assistons à la
période actuelle nous ne faisons pas
notre la politique du président de la
république ou un homme décide de tout et
pour tout le monde parti communiste
français
c'est une équipe une grande qui
d'ailleurs on le voit plusieurs reprises
dans ce film et je l'en félicite
on boit avec les membres du comité
central avec des amis dans ma
circonscription villejuif a vécu avec
mes collaborateurs
le parti communiste c'est une équipe et
au sein de cette équipe
vous qui a des responsabilités georges
marchais mais ce qui compte avant tout
c'est équipe
je vous remercie la manche